So, I made a new short film.
Yay! Well done, Charlie.
Lots of people said nice things about it.
Thank you very much to you folks,
but there were also a fair amount of people
who said some less than nice things about it,
and, what are the odds, now all I want to
do is talk about dealing with criticism.
First thing you need to get in your head
when it comes to taking criticism
is to remember that it is not
inherently a bad thing.
Try, if you can, to be thankful that anybody
is bothering to criticize you at all
because that is so much better than someone
looking at something that you've made
and being like,
"Yeah, it was alright."
That's not even
really a reaction.
If someone's criticizing, you what
it means is that they are
paying attention to what you've made,
they are engaging with it,
and they're taking it seriously,
and those are not bad things.
The problem, really, just comes
in that isn't how it feels,
especially if you've been working
on something for a long time
because I think that, in my experience,
the longer that I've been working on a project,
the more that project feels like
a reflection of me personally.
What I like to do is to try and create
much distance as I possibly can
between myself and the thing that I have
made because if that distance isn't there,
you're gonna look at criticism and
you're going to take it personally.
And really, the simplest way you can create
that distance is you just have to wait.
You just have to resist looking at
those YouTube comments,
and then, eventually, that
distance will just create itself.
The next step for me, once I've
created that distance, is that
I like to read the negative criticism, and
maybe this sounds weird, but, personally,
as much as I love people telling me that
what I've done is great, who doesn't?
It feels lovely. I just kinda thing that, often times,
the negative stuff is more useful.
It's not all gonna be useful. Obviously,
a lot of it will be people just being dicks
because that's what
people are like.
They like to tear stuff apart because
it makes them feel good.
Naturally, some of it is going to be like really
well thought out, really well meaning,
it will make perfect sense, but you just won't
agree with it. It's just not your taste.
That's completely fine,
but then there's the stuff,
and it's always there, it's
always in there somewhere.
You'll just look at it and you'll
be like, "You know what,
if I had done that, yes, it would
have been better. Okay.
Oh well. What is the lesson I can take
from this to apply to the next thing I do?"
Now just as important as
knowing how to take criticism,
of course, is knowing how
to dish it out as well,
and the number one rule that I try
and stick to is, "Don't be a dick."
You just have to try and
remember that all the time,
there is a person behind that thing
that you just experienced
who might not be able to distance themselves
from that thing that they made,
and, especially if you're leaving a comment
on the Internet, they will likely see it,
they'll take it personally, and they'll feel bad,
and you won't have helped anyone.
I just see it so often when like someone is
trying to give good advice to someone else,
but they're just not going
about it the right way,
and to me, it's analogous to like writing
down the advice on a piece of paper,
putting it in a clenched fist, and punching the
person that they're trying to advise in the face.
They can very well be like, "I had the advice,
it was right there, it's good."
It was right there in
front of you."
But all they're going to think is,
"You punched in the face!
You pu-- I don't like you."
And honestly, learning how to hand
someone that advice isn't that hard.
All you need to do is tell them what you
liked about what they made
and tell them what you think
could improved. That's it.
If all you do is tell them what you hated,
they're not going to listen to you.
So with all of that, hopefully now you'll
think I'm being genuine when I say,
"Thank you so much for watching my film.
Thank you for all of the positive comments.
Thank you for all of the negative
comments unless, of course,
you're just being a dick, and let's
hope the next film is better,
that I learn some stuff, or else,
what's the point."  Bye!
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
(TYPEWRITER CLICKING)
And in a turn of events that has surprised the world,
Charlie put a link to his short film
at the end of his video.
I hope you watch it if you
haven't already,
but if you don't, it's ultimately not going
to be a problem. (DOOR SQUEAKS)
And now it's gone.
You missed your chance.
(SIGH) Typical.